[Music]
for me reinvention has meant like an
evolution especially considering you
know I came into the industry I was very
very young fifteen years old still
trying to figure out who I was as a
young woman but also as my own artist
and now I have the opportunity to
showcase that not only to the world but
also to myself so it's just really cool
just to see the transformation and
seeing the growth in such a short amount
of time you know a lot of what I did
when I was younger like my parents I
could not keep still I would be in the
house
tumbling dancing they were like okay we
need to put this girl in something so I
was very used to doing multiple things
at one time and I don't know I just
always had just a work ethic and I want
to be better and to be the best that I
could possibly be so I think that a lot
of that kind of contributes into my
artistry right now like I will have
nights like I don't sleep it's the one
thing that keeps me up at night just to
make sure that my vision comes to life
not only for everybody else around me
and I amazing fans who deserve nothing
but the best but also just to meet my
expectation which is so incredibly high
so as long as I match that and anything
that I do whatever I'm offering to the
rest of the world I'm happy
and I'm able to sleep I wear so many
different hats sometimes a manager has
something to calm down thank you I'm not
a control freak
but when it comes to my business I just
I mean I have a certain expectation and
I'd like to make sure that things don't
fall through a lot of the time I have to
step away and kind of silence everybody
else's voice and think okay what is my
goal what's the ultimate where do I see
the end-all be-all and I think that it's
a matter of getting everybody on your
team on the same page as well and being
able to recognize and respect that and
make sure that they're working twice as
hard as you if everybody's not working
twice as hard as you if not harder than
[Music]
I think back to me being a little girl
and being able to see some of my
favorite artists young black women which
I hope to be the representation of today
you know even for the next generation to
inspire them and let them know that they
can also do what I'm doing you know I'm
no different than they are I'm a regular
girl from the south who had a dream and
I worked really really hard I had an
amazing family and support system thank
God but I'm no different just continue
to work hard and remember that the
possibilities are
[Music]